relations bilatérales
alors vous le voyez le maire de montréal
qui poursuit son opération charme cette
fois à paris il était avec un hidalgo
maire de paris voyage en europe qui va
le conduire dans plusieurs capitales
compte rendu notre journal est ce là bas
alexandre rocha ce cas derrière
l'imposante façade de l'hôtel de ville
de paris de mère d'horizon politique
bien différent aurait difficilement pu
être plus complices au bout d'une heure
le tutoiement était de rigueur et une
entente signée afin de faciliter
l'installation des entreprises
montréalaises à paris donc en europe et
vice versa pour la socialiste anne
hidalgo la coopération avec montréal
c'est tout bénéfice et je pense qu'on a
beaucoup à apprendre
nous à paris de montréal beaucoup d'
échanges possibles sur les questions du
développement durable sur les questions
de transports urbains mais aussi sur les
questions sociales moi je suis intéressé
par aussi le modèle de montréal sur les
questions de traitement de la grande
pauvreté dans nos rues pour le maire de
montréal le lien de confiance établie
avec l'élu de paris mais aussi la veille
avec celui de lyon la seconde ville de
france sont essentiels il ce lien de
confiance un même nécessairement
éventuellement des investissements parce
que les gens tout le monde se parle et
quand le politique ici envoie comme
message que il ya montréal sait faire
ben il nécessairement sur le plan
financier
aude a demandé afin les bandits faut y
aller pour denis coderre qui a aussi
rencontré le secrétaire général de
l'organisation internationale de la
francophonie et le président de la
région de l'île de france ce voyage
européen ouvre un nouveau chapitre
ce qui est important c'est d'envoyer un
message très clair que nous sommes de
retour - revient de loin
nous sommes de retour alors on est prêts
à jouer pleinement trop on est ravi que
montréal ronde
message reçu dix sur dix par le
président de metropolis l'association
des grandes villes du monde
cofondée par montréal dont la métropole
québécoise s'est retiré à la suite du
scandale de corruption
ellle aura dorénavant de nouvelles
responsabilités
le voyage européen de denis coderre
pourrait avoir des retombées concrètes
plus rapidement qu'on ne le pense
un investissement français sur le point
d'être annoncés
il créera un siège social nord-américain
et une centaine d'emplois à montréal
ici alexandra schatz qu'à radio-canada
paris